we've seen attack ships on fire off the
shoulder of Orion see beams glittering
in the dark near the Tannhauser gate and
now it looks like we'll get to see a
blade on a sequel sooner than you think
I'm Simon and this is your replicant
chasing news update the wait for the
blade runner sequel just got a little
shorter it was announced this week that
the movie will come to theaters in
October 2017 three months earlier than
its previous January 2018 release window
variety reported that more specifically
the film will arrive on october six 2017
if that date sounds familiar it's
because it was the release date for the
new jungle book movie from anti-surface
and warner brothers but that has now
been shifted talked over 2018 the new
blade runner film stars Ryan Gosling and
Harrison Ford while Robin Wright and
Dave Bautista will also appear in the
movie it's being directed by the man
behind Sicario Denny Villeneuve from a
script written by original blade on a
co-writer hampton fancher and Michael
Green Roger Deakins a cinematography
legend who received Oscar nominations
for the Shawshank Redemption Fargo and o
brother where art thou among others is
also working on the film production is
scheduled to begin in July 1982's Blade
Runner was based on Phillip K dicks 1968
dystopian novel do androids dream of
electric sheep there is no word yet on
what the story will be for the sequel
but the movie produced by original Blade
Runner director Ridley Scott will take
place several decades after the event
the first one will the blade runner seek
will become a classic like its
predecessor or will it just become a
moment lost in time like tears in the
rain let me know what you think in the
comments or come find me on Twitter i'm
at the Jagan or thanks for watching and
for all your entertainment news keep it
gamespot